I think most of the 20th century saw a
huge wave of this homogenous a shin but
I think it's also important to to
remember that this wave of
homogenization was never complete and
this proved to be really difficult for
companies as they sought to globalize
the industry to give some examples so as
companies pushed out their brands and
entered different markets they
discovered often to their surprise that
different cultures different societies
continued to have some very distinct arm
preferences which were very hard to
shift so the United States was a huge
consumer of makeup Europeans and
stations much spent much greater on
skincare East Asians hardly spent on
perfume and whatever companies did they
so far failed to raise to raise that the
French had disproportionate spending on
perfumes so for all the modernization
going on in how we meant to be beautiful
persistent national differences were
still noticeable and my argument is that
globalization in the last 20 years has
started to work in the opposite
direction from how it worked previously
I think globalization is spreading
diversity now rather than rather than
constricting it and there's a number of
reasons number of reasons why this is
happening one is that you know in the
major Western nation United States or
France populations are ethnically very
diverse now so those there are simply a
lot of different marketing opportunities
that companies wish to to take advantage
of but also the rise of
of our power and wealth of countries
like China India and and Russia is
suddenly making their beauty ideals
aspirational perhaps certainly
impossible certainly impossible to to
ignore so the major players in the
industry now are very interested in
supplying those markets for sure but
also experimenting with taking their
beauty ideals and brands derived from
those ideals back to Western countries
as as consumers now increasingly seek
greater diversity in what it means to be
beautiful
I'm argued that we've seen a greater
diversity in beauty ideals in recent
decade or so you could say that it's an
orchestrated diversity and the great
example of of that I think is loyal
loyal is a French company of course from
the early 20th century through to their
1980s it was overwhelmingly French
company with a very nice portfolio of
our French or French brands I was
primarily on a hair care company even
then what happened then under the young
and the leadership of lindsay owen jones
the chief executive during the 1990s
they brought a whole portfolio of
American brands including the iconic
Maybelline Red King matrix keels are
three sort of niche brandy in New York
and what they then did was globalize
these brands and took them round the
world so by the early 21st century
lore'l was offering consumers worldwide
a choice French Beauty or American
Beauty it's the same company but they're
offering them in this portfolio of our
brand in intriguing intriguing ways then
in the last ten years they've been
buying brands from other countries and
starting to experiment in the same
direction so the biggest purchase was
the body shop which is a kind of a
British green brand so now they can
offer consumers British style green
nurse they've also brought a probably
the only luxury Chinese beauty brand you
sigh they also brought a an iconic
makeup artist Japanese branch Shamu
and they taking those around the world
too so lore'l is a excellent example but
I think most of the other big companies
now are take have a portfolio of brands
based in different beauty ideals which
they offer to to consumers